en una sesión especial con todos los
honores en una ceremonia en el palacio
de la manera el presidente sebastián
piñera promulgada esta ley que fue
aprobada el martes por una amplia
mayoría tanto de senadores como de
diputados en una rara imagen en la que
se podía ver abrazadas a ambas vaca
bancadas del congreso el presidente
anunció hoy que no podría existir en
chile- familias de primera y de segunda
categoría y que se trata de hacer una
sociedad mucho más digna para todos en
la que las personas con diversa
diversidad sexual puedan gozar de los
mismos derechos y también sus hijos que
el resto de las personas esto hace que a
partir de ahora
se tenga que publicar en el diario
oficial de la república de chile y
transcurridos 90 días el matrimonio
igualitario será una realidad en el país
eso va a coincidir aproximadamente con
el próximo cambio de mando en el que
habrá un nuevo presidente también en el
país
patricia esta decisión llegó cuatro años
después de que el congreso debatiera el
matrimonio igualitario que tan fácil o
qué tan difícil fue esta aprobación
el propio presidente piñera agradecía
hoy en su discurso a michelle bachelet
que fue la persona que ingresó en su
segundo mandato el proyecto de ley en el
congreso y que estuvo ahí durmiendo
durante muchísimo tiempo fue en 2017
llevaba cuatro años dormido en forma
inesperada sin que nadie lo pudiera
presagiar ni siquiera los propios
diputados oficialistas el presidente
piñera anunció en su última cuenta
pública en junio que le iba a poner
máxima urgencia a partir de ahí ha sido
un trámite bastante farragoso con muchas
idas y vueltas cambios en la
nomenclatura en pequeñas palabras lo
hemos seguido de cerca aquí en france24
todos los reveses que ha sufrido hasta
que finalmente el pasado martes toda la
diversidad sexual pero también el resto
de las personas en el país celebraba que
al final al fin esta es una sociedad un
poco más justa que chile se convierte en
el octavo país de la américa latina
donde el matrimonio igualitario ha
reconocido y encarna una de las 30
países en el mundo
unas decenas de países donde los
matrimonios heterosexuales y entre
personas del mismo sexo tienen igualdad
de derechos lo que nos hace a todas las
sociedades en las que vivimos en lugares
así un lugar un poquito más civilizado
injusto para todos